so there's a great scene near the
beginning of shame blocks to the nice
guys which more people should have seen
in theaters by the way you know it
sucked the Angry Birds anyway we're Ryan
Gosling a private investigator breaks
into a bar to get his hands on some
receipts like we've seen people do a
million times before in movies Gosling
is going to break the glass to unlock
the door from inside but things really
don't go as planned
besides being a hilariously funny
reversal and subversion of an old cliche
I think this moment gets to the heart of
Shane Black's interests in awkward
violence and deeper than that in film
Noirs obsession with violence as the
undying backdrop to civilization
speaking of backdrops you may not be
familiar with Shane black but his work
has been in the backdrop of Hollywood
for 30 years now starting as a writer
during the spec script boom of the late
80s 90s and early 2000s when unsolicited
original scripts were in really high
demand black wrote Lethal Weapon 1 & 2
The Last Boy Scout long kiss good night
then went on to direct his written work
in films like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang Iron
Man 3 and finally the nice guys all of
these films share similar themes all
have fractured characters all take place
and dangerous often seeming worlds all
have whipped fast plots reversals
betrayals and plenty of character
revealing banter in other words they all
share the traits of film noir there's a
certain madness I think in a certain
bizarre quality of violence in the wire
films where it's devastating it's not
just ongoing it's not just em clever
it's devastating
at this point we're clearly not lacking
in violence at the movies Blockbuster
and tentpole films are awash in the
stuff explosions car crashes chases
fights you name it there are some
directors and stunt coordinators who are
really good at it for example the
Captain America franchise I think has
mastered a very sharp hard-hitting type
of superhero violence where other
franchises have struggled to meet that
bar but the thing about violence and
superhero films is that it's fun but
never really that consequential
particularly if it's heroes fighting
heroes come on Black Widow you know
these people are slayed until like 2022
right a lot of these films add violence
to the mix to spice up things every 20
minutes or so they write themselves up
to the brink and then let the stunt
coordinators take it from there making
sure a few beats are hit along the way
this isn't necessarily bad sometimes
it's awesome but it's not all that
violence can do the question you should
be asking isn't where you should add
violence but how can you use it take
that scene from the beginning with
Gosling it accomplishes so much in such
a short period of time it subverts a
cliche for comedic effect it's a quick
reversal of narrative momentum
it shows how hapless goslings character
is and an accidental slitting of the
wrist plays into the deeper sadness that
underlies his drunkenness a kind of
Freudian slip Shane Black is a master at
using violence to augment story and
character in his action thrillers and
Nia Noirs want to show that a police
detective is past his prime what if you
want to show that a detective craves
violence in an almost masochistic way in
blacks films the violence is often messy
and shocking and awkward because that's
what real violence is like it's a kind
of chaos a rupture in things the
inciting incident in a long kiss good
night is a perfect example of this Geena
Davis hits a deer with her car which
would be enough to send the car
careening off the road by itself but
black has the deer come through the
windshield still alive kicking the
passenger in the face this is awkward
and transfixing in a way that leaves us
unguarded against the violence of the
moment and consequence we become more
present for the whole scene the pencil
trick in the dark night by the way
achieves a similar
fact another thing black likes to do is
visit violence on an otherwise peaceful
another thing that black likes to do is
visit violence
maybe I should just let black say it in
his own words in this country where we
think everything's settled and stable
and and serene something horribly
violent can intrude upon our peace then
we have to go back to this gunslinger
who knew all along that the war wasn't
over in the West wasn't gentrified black
uses sudden violence not only to shock
the audience but as a way to justify and
animate his heroes and heroines the
point is that this is violence with
narrative purpose that purpose may be as
simple as keeping the audience on their
toes or fingers
I just got have your finger yet it may
be a way to solve a simple problem or it
might reveal what a character's really
like or who he would like to be just fun
non life Elias we all live around
violence but by and large were separate
from it a good new are or thriller lets
us travel to the other side dip our feet
into that current feel how cold it is if
we've had the bad fortune to experience
it firsthand
we know that violence can be
indiscriminate and deeply personal at
the same time
violence done right in these movies
violence as a plot element or an
exhibition of character awkward violence
is violence respected of course at the
end of the day these are just movies
pulpy detective stories genre flicks but
I wouldn't want to live in a universe
that didn't have poppy genre detective
movies like lethal weapon or Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang I think Shane Black is one of
the few action thriller writers who
incorporates violence into his scripts
creatively and I'm glad he's still
getting work for that to keep happening
of course we have to keep going to see
his movies and others like unless that
is you're ok with
the alternative
for the birds hallelujah there is a new
nerdwriter video every Wednesday so if
you go right to that box right there and
click that you'll subscribe and get all
the videos and that's what helps me out
the most in this channel I got to thank
Squarespace for helping to sponsor this
video funding the channel without asking
to interfere in the content which is
really really cool
they make sleek intuitive websites you
don't have to know coding to make one
and if you go to Squarespace comm and
sign up for one year you'll get a free
domain name and if you use the offer
code nerdwriter you'll get 10% off your
first purchase for all you website heads
out there thanks so much I'll see you
guys next Wednesday